okay so we're here at the nottingham
forest football stadium and well we
wanted to find some excuse to use the
stadium so i thought why not talk about
the football itself now it's a very
special shape but i tell you what for
the purpose of this video i'm going to
use this little toy version this is a
bit clearer to see
now this is actually a special
mathematical shape it's called a
truncated icosahedron but
what is an icosahedron let's start with
that so this prop slightly less
glamorous i'm afraid it's a homemade
prop i made it out of cardboard myself
but this is the icosahedron it has 20
triangular faces and it looks like this
so now if i cut off the corners of this
shape we have 12 corners if i cut them
off i will now make my football shape
the truncated
icosahedron so the truncated icosahedron
has 12 pentagon faces here they are in
black
and 20 hexagon faces there they are in
white and they fit together and this is
your traditional football this was used
in professional games since the 1970s
and has been more recently replaced with
a modern ball which actually uses fewer
panels now there is an advantage though
to using the old fashion ball because
although it's slightly counter-intuitive
the stitching around the ball makes it a
bit more rough makes the surface a bit
more rough and it actually makes it more
aerodynamic the what they find with
their modern balls because they're
smoother and are less rough they're
actually less
aerodynamic
[Music]
so they have to artificially add dimples
and artificial grooves and stitching so
that it will have the same sort of
flight as the old fashion balls did yeah
so this shape was also used by an
american architect called bucky fuller
who used to build domes in this shape
and it's him that they named the bookie
ball after the bookie ball is this shape
yeah you may have heard of the bookie
ball it's
also used in chemistry because it's a
it's a molecule of 60 carbon atoms again
forming
this shape the truncated icosahedron so
in a buckyball we have these 60 atoms
which are the corners
of this truncated icosahedron shape
making the same shape as this football
mix